hey everyone this is Jared a creator of
8-bit philosophy and we've got a special
episode for you guys today
while many games are certainly
philosophical very few are as effective
at integrating philosophical concepts
into the plot as Bioshock not only is
the Bioshock trilogy a pioneer of
gameplay mixing elements of survival
horror RPGs and FPS games but it also
flaunts a level of intellectual
sophistication rarely seen in games
welcome to this special episode on the
philosophy of Bioshock oh and viewers
keep in mind we are skipping the second
game who is John Galt is the cryptic
question posed and Atlas Shrugged the
most famous book by russian-born thinker
iron Rand
similarly who is Atlas posters adorn the
wall of rapture transforming the
original question of rands work in the
book John Galt engineer genius and
heartthrob encourages a strike of the
mind where all the world's
industrialists are encouraged to leave
their roles in an increasingly
controlling regulated and rule driven
world frustrated with the inefficiency
of socialism and its lack of care for
the individual and their hard work Galt
retreats to Galt's Gulch in order to
shut down the industrial motor of the
world the original BioShock takes place
in rapture a digital homage to Galt's
Gulch in which all the world's best
minds were brought together undersea by
one man Andrew Ryan the name Andrew Ryan
is effectively an anagram for Iran more
or less Andrew Ryan's political
philosophy is lifted right from rands
concept of Objectivism objectivism is a
sort of guide to living a worthy life
its main tenants are reality reason
self-interest and capitalism basically
ran believes that reality is concrete
and objective there's no point in
talking about the mystical divine and
supernatural as guiding forces for
Humanity actions should be determined
solely on the basis of intellect an
easier way to say this is that Iran is
an atheist and apparently so is Andrew
Ryan I believe in no God no invisible
man in the sky
but there is something more powerful
than each of us a combination of our
efforts a great chain of industry that
unites us
Andrew Ryan serves as a mouthpiece for
rands condemnation of coercive
governments in favor of a society based
in radical self-interest but it is only
when we struggle in our own interest
that the chains pull Society in the
right direction
rapture was founded on the belief that
the Communist parasites in the world
above were freeloaders that stole
violated and unjustly took from the
captains of industry
Ryan was tired of working and not
getting what he deserved
just like Galt it belongs to God
no says the man in Moscow it belongs to
everyone I also like Ryan ran was a
proponent of lays a fair capitalism or
the idea that a good government exists
only to protect individual rights and
stays out of people's personal lives on
the market similarly in the world
rapture the plasmon market is severely
under regulated the belief is that the
unfettered market provides the best
option for consumers tremendous pressure
to regulate this plasmid business have
been side-effects - but what use is our
ideology
[Applause]
so what went wrong
does the ruinous state of rapture
suggests that a society run by such
tenants is doomed to fail or did Ryan
pervert trans beliefs this is where Adam
comes in
Adam is a resource so potent that it led
to a civil war between Ryan and Fontaine
or Atlas due to ryan's ideals of a free
market economy adam was completely
deregulated creating a population of
addicts riddled with side effects
resulting in rampant chaos and
instability or perhaps Ryan's simply
misused Rand's philosophy using the
little sisters as mules for magical sea
slugs to create Adam certainly treats
them as mere tools for your own goals
and Miss Rand would certainly disapprove
[Music]
now let's be clear the trendy discussion
on BioShock Infinite has something to do
with quantum entanglement and
multiverses and while it's a great
discussion it's already been covered ad
nauseam we're going to abbreviate the
discussion because while science is hard
the third installment of the Bioshock
series moves from the underwater world
of rapture to the floating city Columbia
a play on the United States Capitol
Columbia is a sort of floating Eden
founded by a man named Zachary Hale
Comstock Comstock is a fictional
stand-in for a 19th century New York
political figure Anthony Comstock famous
for his fight against obscenity and his
rather prudish values the Comstock
character mirrors Anthony's public feud
with noted anarchist Emma Goldman who is
doubled by Daisy Fitzroy Comstock founds
Columbia with the promise of providing a
place for God's people apart from the
world of sinners in the Sodom below this
image of Columbia as a shining beacon in
the sky has its philosophical
justification in the concept of American
exceptionalism American exceptionalism
is the belief that the new world was
promised to God's chosen people
and through this philosophy BioShock
Infinite provides us with a tasty satire
of America's historical landscape
American exceptionalism is a way of
justifying a particular lifestyle
Columbia like America is considered
God's country forgiveness of sins
salvation and baptism are all religious
themes and infinite but like its
predecessor this game explores the dark
side of this philosophy
[Music]
similar to Comstock's Colombia the
expansion into the new frontier was
justified as a mission from God
to ensure that the newer world doesn't
backslide like the old world sinners of
Europe America was to be a land
populated by exceptional chosen people
exempt and above the rest of the world
secularized as manifest destiny American
exceptionalism justifies and demands the
extermination of the indigenous people
of the wilderness aka Native Americans
for the sake of securing the national
identity of the Christian settlers those
not willing to accept Christianity were
forcibly moved or eliminated American
exceptionalism is not just a question of
land the ideology of this philosophy is
inextricably woven into the fabric of
history slavery labor strikes the abuses
of the Irish and Chinese workers who
built the American railroad system are
all justified by the lofty goal of a
promised City for God's people fearful
of the anarchist Vox Populi afraid of
the Irish and Chinese threat and scared
of racial mixing Colombia is a paranoid
place infinite explores America's
haunted past the Battle of Wounded Knee
which is considered the end of the US
and Indian Wars is heralded laws
enforcing racial segregation and
lynching are not just the norm they're
commonplace perhaps this is why the
enemies in the game are robotic George
Washington is called Patriots come on
folks show your allegiance to flag end
to the nation
[Music]
hey what are you doing
are you gonna throw it are you taking
your coffee black these days with
BioShock Infinite we get the prospect
that the hero Booker DeWitt is
simultaneously the villain Bioshock
exposes the paranoia of an
us-versus-them dichotomy it challenges
our conception of good guys and bad guys
of freedom fighters revolutionaries
dictators and terrorists kill little
sisters or save them throw a ball at an
interracial couple or at the racist
announcer accept or reject the baptismal
forgiveness of sins
one of the essential dilemmas of
Bioshock is the freedom of action choice
and free will for those of you that
don't know me my name is matt pat and i
run a channel called the game theorists
thanks a lot to wisecrack for having me
on today and that being said let's get
into it this is the importance of choice
and free will even Bioshock in the first
Bioshock we're told quote Andrew Ryan
reminds us we all make choices but in
the end our choices make us end quote so
if we make choices we must be free but
then again if our choices make us then
how can we be free to make them this
conundrum leads us to the question is
free will even possible one school of
thought known as hard determinism
suggests that there's no such thing as
free will if all action can be boiled
down to cause and effect then all of our
actions are always bound by an external
force even you dear viewer may think
you're free to click off this video
right now
but keep in mind that if you do there's
a reason you're doing so so the question
is are you truly free in your actions or
are your actions a result of a series of
events that you had nothing to do with
our choice in our actions is merely an
illusion
Andrew Ryan reiterates this with the
phrase man chooses
the slave obeys and what is perhaps the
most brilliant part of the original game
Andrew Ryan makes a statement on the
nature of gaming itself and how you as a
gamer are destined to mindlessly follow
the fixed path of the game's narrative
and interactivity or the idea that you
have any bearing on how the game will
turn out is merely an illusion BioShock
Infinite presents a possible way out of
the problem of free will the multiverse
an infinite number of worlds to choose
from the fact that Booker's able to go
back and choose not to be baptized to
smother baby Comstock in his crib seems
to be a way out of the deterministic
universe that's the only way to do it go
back to what he was born
Smothers except that this very choice
isn't a real possibility even when it
seems that there is choice for the
player the game hints at the problem of
freewill the first choice to flip a coin
is very interesting you're prompted with
the quote-unquote choice to press X
except in reality you are not free to
not flip if you never press X the game
doesn't progress it just stays there but
if you do press X to flip well it always
ends up heads or consider the scene at
which booker is prompted the choice to
bring us to go and wipe away the debt
you're free to walk around the room the
game even presents you with the option
of pressing ax to handle is a bit over
yet the only way to progress in the game
is to press X and pick baby Elizabeth up
you don't leave this room until you do
even though press X is an option that
you can seemingly deny the game proves
that this choice is merely an illusion
you are fated to handle is a bit over
whereas most games would just show this
event in a cutscene Bioshock makes you
press X it forces you to recognize that
you are in fact not free and that
anything that indicates otherwise is
merely an illusion perhaps the only way
to truly assert your freedom in the
world of BioShock is to simply turn off
the game jump through this dimensional
tear by clicking here to see the
ice crack crew debate it out against
matpat which game is more of an artistic
masterpiece The Last of Us or pacman
be sure to check out the wisecrack
channel page and subscribe for more
smart stuff and hey help us win the
debate by hopping over to that video and
casting your vote for us that seems
relatively unfair you're just afraid the
wisecrack army is gonna take you down
well at the end of the day the choice of
whether to click or not is theirs or is
it you see what I did there that's a
reference to the Bioshock philosophy
video we just did where we're talking
about free will and the ability to
choose or not to choose in these sorts
of games the type of highbrow
educational humor that you can expect
here both unwise crack also on my chant
well my channel is just a lot of really
bad puns self-deprecating humor we get
an occasional witty one in there nice
musical theater reference every now and
then anyway they should click out over
and subscribe subscribe to wise crack
subscribe to the game theorists really
you can't go wrong
[Music]
[Music]